OK, real quick voicemail about vaccination.
Take a listen to this.
Yeah.
Hey, David, Stan and Marina Valley really
liked your show, but I have a question if,
if and when the core virus vaccine becomes
available, will you be raising your hand to
be first in line to get the vaccine?
The reason I ask is because I noticed your
team be very critical of anti batters.
Well, yeah, and it's not that I'm anti batter
or anything like that, but I think I'm not
nearly as confident as you are about the use
of them.
So I appreciate a.
An answer on that.
The answer is, I will absolutely be at the
front of the line now.
I won't be allowed at the front of the line
in the sense that the vaccine, after being
tested on thousands and thousands of people
in each each vaccine will be tested on many,
many people in the first few million doses
are going to go to health care workers.
The next ones are going to go to health care
workers and the most vulnerable population.
So even if I wanted to be first in line for
the vaccine, once it had been properly tested,
I'm not going to be first in line.
Right.
Because as someone in my thirties without
preexisting conditions, there is not a priority
to get me the vaccine.
Health care workers and vulnerable people.
But, yes, I will be there looking to get a
corona virus vaccine.
Make sure you don't miss today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
join Packman dot com.
I will see you on the bonus show.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.